hey youtubers is Charlie whole bunch of
flash knowledge bombs dropped this
weekend so this is going to be my top 10
predictions for the rest of the season
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video
winners are always announced at the end
of videos so be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything so we got to talk about black
flash we got to talk about grodd's so
levar and while I'm doing this just let
me know if you think the audio is a
little bit better than my previous
videos I just changed the way I do a
little bit so top 10 predictions for the
back half of the season number 10 Jesse
quick and Harrison wells of earth 2 will
be back very soon the reason they're not
on all the time is just because they
have so many characters already and they
wanted to feel different fresh with new
characters or albeit you know different
characters with new personalities like
Tom Cavanagh who plays like a different
version of his character every single
season so because they want to feel like
there's all these Jesse quick adventures
happening on earth too while we're
having all the adventures on earth one
with regular team flash they just have
to allow that to exist by itself and
they just choose to fill it in when she
tells stories like oh my god I had all
these adventures or even if she ever
goes off on one of the new spin-off TV
shows so there's always the chance that
they could do like a Teen Titans or a
Young Justice live-action show so Jesse
quick would be like the prime candidate
for that if she's not going to be on the
main flash show every single week or she
could always go to legends of tomorrow
in a future season but number 9 that
also means that earth 19 Harrison wells
will be here at least long enough to
introduce us to earth 19 flash who seems
like he's going to be a big part of the
gorilla grodd episode so no ideas if
he's going to stay for the entire season
but he will be here for a while longer
I know he came on kind of strong but
that was him just like laying it on
thick so that the team would like him
now that they've cooled off a little bit
he's cooled off a little bit so I don't
think he's going to be quite as crazy in
the back half of the season he'll still
be very different from earth-2 Harrison
wells
but that's just because he's a different
character so we can all lay bets when we
get to season 4 predictions on what new
character Tom Cavanagh is gonna play
so I know everybody thinks that he has
some secret agenda beyond the book that
he's writing but really his core mission
the back half of the season is in
launching the STAR Labs Museum kind of
like they had on earth too which I feel
like is a precursor to the flash Museum
which we'll eventually see on the show
but maybe not this season number eight
this is a big one
earth 19 flash the accelerated man will
be someone different than Barry so what
I think they're gonna do is is if they
want to have him on screen with Grant
Gustin at the same time it would just
make sense
that you would use a different actor it
would be like a different person from
Barry so they could interact with each
other and have a really cool adventure
there are a number of different people
that it could be if it's going to be
someone that we've seen before like oh
my god I can't believe he's the flash of
another earth but the thing is is the
accelerated man is from Grant Morrison's
Multiversity storyline which is kind of
non-canonical like it's like this weird
spin-off story that exists by itself but
in that story you never learn who's
underneath the mask you just see him in
that Red Baron looking costume with the
scarf wrapped around his face so he's
like a really small one-off character
they could just do the same thing and
never reveal who's underneath there you
I mean you could just guess just based
on the way his eye line looks even if he
doesn't take the scarf off in the
episode we'll have to listen to him
speak at least a little bit so we'll
probably be able to figure out who it is
but number 7 the gorilla grodd two-part
episode will take place on gorilla city
of earth - not earth 19 as previously
believed so the whole reason that
everyone thought that the gorilla grodd
episodes would take place on earth 19
was because of the presence of earth 19
flash so everyone's like oh okay we're
going to go to our new Harrison wells
from Earth 19 birth will meet his
version of the flash he even told us
that they have a gorilla grodd in a
gorilla city on earth 19 server ones
like okay got it
but then this past weekend at the TCAs
the producers dropped all these flash
knowledge bombs instead that it would
actually be on earth to gorilla City
which makes sense because it would be
our version of Gorilla Grodd that we'd
be seeing again so it's a little more
meaningful but it also complicates
things because you know how do you get
earth 19 flash what's he doing there so
next big thing we're honored to number
six will finally meet so levar he'll be
voiced by Keith David who you probably
remember from a whole bunch of stuff but
because he's only going to be using his
voice I think more about the animated
stuff that he does my very favorite
Keith David character is reversed
giraffe from Rick and Morty he's
absolutely amazing no matter what he
does but the Rick and Morty stuff is
crazy maybe just maybe we're all real
you know me I'm reverse giraffe I have a
short neck and legs I went to college
with hammer ah hey I saved ghost in the
jaws life in Vietnam and Beth how many
times have I been a shoulder for you to
cry oh ah too many okay so maybe we're
just all things so if you don't know who
so levar is I'll talk a lot more about
him when we get to that gorilla City
episode but he's basically the good
gorilla in this Planet of the Apes style
fight with gorilla grodd Gorilla Grodd
is one of the biggest flash villains but
we haven't really seen him be a villain
on the series before he's just someone
that gets co-opted by the reverse-flash
and he's a villain of circumstance like
he doesn't want to kill people he just
wants to create more intelligent
gorillas so that he isn't so lonely but
now he's found himself in gorilla City
on earth too with other intelligent Apes
so he's probably tried to seize power
so levar is the other side of that
equation like the Caesar in the Planet
of the Apes equation if you haven't seen
that movie
Caesar isn't an evil ape he's somebody
that starts out as a good character he
winds up fighting for dominance with
another ape that wants to kill all
humans so it becomes this big mess so
it's going to be like battle for the
Planet of the Apes only with gorillas
so battle for the Planet of the gorillas
but if you've never read the comics
gorilla city is amazing we'll talk all
about it when we get closer to that
episode so number 5 we will see Barry
betray the team in order to save iris
we've heard sabotage flash prophecy one
of the people is going to betray team
flash but they were like centered on
Cisco the camera was looking at him when
they said that part of the prophecy but
I actually think that in small ways
Barry is going to betray
the team because he hasn't told everyone
what's going on with iris in the future
and he knows that he can't change the
past but now he's worried about taking
actions that will lead to iris being
killed so he's trying to avoid that
future by doing different things so
that's a big thing in the next episode
you will see him afraid to take down
plunder because he knows that if he
takes plunder down it might lead to iris
being killed so this is only the
beginning like you see him drawing on
this board here he's gonna try and work
out how to change the future by taking
different actions but most of us who
have watched time-travel stories know
that self-fulfilling prophecies tend to
work against you when you try to avoid
them like whatever you try to do it's
always going to lead to that moment time
will always find a way to replace the
terrible thing that you're trying to
avoid which is really interesting
because that's a reverse flash quote he
told that to him in season 1 and now the
reverse flash is over on legends of
tomorrow trying to change time to get
rid of Barry so the reverse flash
actually has a plan to make that stick
involving the spear of destiny I'll talk
more about that in my legends of
tomorrow videos because it's all about
getting rid of Barry Allen but Barry is
trying to change time to save iris so
number 4 like I said you know time likes
to replace terrible things with equally
terrible things we're going to see iris
die more than once in that moment so
when keeping with the theme that Barry
is going to be unable to change time at
least in the short term we're going to
see that moment again now a lot of you
have asked like is iris West going to
die this season Candice Patton is not
going to leave the show meaning there's
going to have to be some crazy
explanation for how Barry saves her or
how she comes back right now without
more evidence the easiest way for Barry
to safer is to pull her from the
timeline and just like stick her inside
the Speed Force a place of pure energy
that exists in this nexus of space and
time in this really weird way so the
only real way to save her right now is
to just pull her out of space-time and
that's the Speed Force but that doesn't
mean that he's actually going to do that
because if you're inside the Speed Force
then that means that Salvator can also
get you
cuz he's stuck inside the speedforce so
number three escaping death the black
flash will be back but it's going to be
a different person underneath the mask
so if there's any confusion the black
flash is a little bit different from
zoom is a little bit different from the
black racer there's a lot of different
flashes that we're black costumes so it
can get a little confusing the black
flash originally started out is sort of
this meta concept of villain created by
Grant Morrison and Mark Millar to come
for Wally West
so that Wally could metaphorically and
literally escape death like his own
death was chasing him he was able to
outrace it so it was kind of a
metaphorical story like it was their way
to show that Wally had evolved as a
human being as a flash as a character
his powers had gotten to the point where
he was so good that he like broken the
mortal chains and could literally outrun
the concept of death meaning that he was
effectively immortal this all happened
right before Jeff John started writing
on the flash but then later during Jeff
John's run he actually turned him into
more of a physical character during Jeff
John's run he started using the
character is more of an antagonist so on
the TV show it's more of like a Jeff
John's black flash someone who comes
preceding the death of a speedster so he
only shows up when a speedster is
getting ready to die it could be any
speedster not anyone in particular so
when the black flash is killed or dies a
new flash takes his place so there was a
brief period when Barry Allen during
Jeff John's run became the black flash
then later
eobard thawne professor zoom became the
black flash during blackest night so a
couple different versions of the flash
have been the black flash but on the TV
show it's zoom so when he comes back it
will be the black flash it's not going
to be zoom coming back in because the
actor who played zoom is on another TV
show they've just said that it'll
probably be somebody else underneath the
makeup but when you look at him here
like you can't really tell this is Teddy
Sears like it just looks like a lot of
CG so it's not really that big a deal
but it is the same zoom but you have to
imagine that going through that
transformation changed his personality
so it'll be more like a zombies story
and we'll talk more about this when I do
season 4 predictions but this also gives
them a backdoor to do a blackest night
zombies storyline in season 4 like a
black flash team-up of evil flashes the
other really cool thing about that is
they said that the black flash will show
up on multiple TV shows which makes it
sound like he's going to come for the
reverse-flash on legends of tomorrow so
we'll just wait and see about that
number two though is that we will see
human forms avatar we'll learn what he
looked like before he learned to create
his Speed Force armor so there is a
person who is sabotage even though he's
like a full CG villain right now with
Tobin Bell from the Saw franchise doing
his voice so that's sort of like monster
forms avatar who calls himself a god but
as we know he's not a god you just need
to get people to believe that you're a
god in order to make it true so
eventually towards the end of the season
we'll learn what he looks like when he
doesn't have his armor on like that but
right now he's sort of stuck in a state
between pure energy in the Speed Force
and being an actual physical person on
earth so he's going to be like this
until the flash learns how to defeat him
so that's probably going to be most of
the back half of the season
but speaking of shiny suits number one
we will see Barry in a new flash suit so
there's a couple different ways this
could happen Grant Gustin already teased
that it's time for Barry to get a new
suit so what happens each year on the
flash is that they upgrade the suit just
a little bit like we go from the red
emblem to the white emblem Cisco adds
special new abilities the only thing
that they haven't done yet that they've
teased is the flash ring so that's going
to be one upgrade but I also think that
because Barry keeps trying to see the
future we will see a future version of
the suit like he's slowly becoming the
future flash the more antagonistic one
that goes against the group because of
this iris situation it's driving him
crazy so it's putting him at odds with
the rest of team flash so that's where
you have your future flash storyline
where Barry sends them the message don't
trust anyone you can't trust me which
gets into the legends of tomorrow plot
changing time future flash
or so there's just like so much
craziness that they've teased that they
have left to do so in case you forgot it
don't worry I'll be doing bonus videos
for everything as we get closer to the
season it's still a couple weeks away
there's probably going to be a new
trailer next week if you guys have
requests for bonus videos just leave
them in the comments but congratulations
to the new flash giveaway winner
resident evil freak 500 you win a
reverse flash ring please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details for
those that are asking giveaway winners
are always announced at the end of
videos so make sure to stick around to
the end of videos so that you know
whether or not you want to give away and
that's the same for all the videos that
I do so new Batman movie stuff coming
tonight where you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn about
Thor Ragnarok and the death of the
Marvel Universe and you can click here
to learn all about Gorilla Grodd on the
flash thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video
you